thank you for bringing up the house
lights a little bit for us so we can see
how much better you've heard it all so
much today already but congratulations
then today is for you we we know what
you've been through we did it a long
time ago so one of the things that I
would say right away is if your parents
are here be sure to thank them because
they supported you through this endeavor
and it's a very important thing and you
know they'll enjoy it when you get to
bring them to TV shows or others yeah
famous famous doing I've always
described our experience at Carnegie
Mellon not unlike that if we had
attended Hogwarts because it is a unique
weird place in this odd little city at
the confluence of Three Rivers in the
middle of most people think nowhere and
because of that you have the most unique
experience that can be imagined because
you are put together and you become a
chosen family and as you go from here
out into where in all directions
you know many LA many New York other
places you will always have that family
that your chosen family from
I would say that in Los Angeles all of
our best friends are people that we went
to school with so you know it's all it's
becomes friendships that we've known for
40 years and that in turn becomes the
Alumni Association well forty five years
ago but it becomes the people that you
that you depend on to hear about work
they help you they become colleagues you
will work with them on different
projects so every all of you together
will probably spend your lifetimes
working together and but to add you
aren't because you're the chosen you've
chosen your family the family that has
gone ahead of you to all of these places
is also part of your family and so if
you come to LA and you find us which is
pretty easy to do we will you'll become
part of our family and you'll become
part of all of the members of the West
Coast drama alumni clan and which is a
very active group and we always have a
good Christmas party and events during
[Music]
Goodbar always always always but that's
part that's part of the experience of
Carnegie Mellon and I'm only repeating
what president said is about you joined
the community of alumni that have gone
ahead and because they've experienced
this unique weird Hogwarts experience
they're there because and they
understand the kind of magical time
you've had here so they're willing and
they're there and we're there to help
you succeed so that's a lot of words to
say keep in touch
so how are you never know and I think I
think that's probably all I want to say
today I was not I was adding bill to
things I have to tell number one Peter
they've never remembered to put in that
I was the chairman of the television
Academy and gave out the Emmy Awards not
not that I gave any to me but a lot of
the certificates I had to me I had to
sign for me and Joe nominations you know
oh so the other day I was we had an
intern actually from Emerson and we had
nothing to do so we said could you
please it figure out how many shows
we've done so she sat down and got on
IMDB and she went through our portfolio
and she looked at our you know two long
resume and she came up finally with the
gist in the sitcom category that I had
worked on a hundred and thirty-five
pilots and out of those 52 had gone into
series so I said does this mean we
finally get to graduate and here we are
how we graduated anyway and Joe between
between us together and in the work with
with the entertainment music variety
special event talk show game show awards
show so we did a etcetera beauty
pageants in between gigs with Carol
Burnett and you know Michael Buble Joe
has come up with we figured out over 600
hours of television and that's not
counting that 23 years of the Jerry
Lewis telethon which was 24 hours long
so that's not counting that we kind of
that is one hour so anyway well in
whiskey we're talking too long we've got
to get on to your party to go into your
graduation and receiving your diplomas
on to your parties and when you're in
Los Angeles to be sure to look us up
we'll see if we can help
[Music]
I have one thing left to say you know
Joe now that we're graduated do you
think we could get married
[Applause]